hallo leute ich es wieder einmal waren
willkommen zu einem neuen koch video der
ganz besonderen art und zwar möchte ich
heute kellys waffel video chatten oder
wie kelly sagen würde ich habe leider
kein sturm war für assistenten da dafür
ist mein lama bei mir sagt alle halo
dafür dass wir da will und mehr muss es
eigentlich nicht gesagt werden
deshalb lasst uns loslegen ach ja wenn
man letztes video gesehen hat das sind
touristen die nicht so einfach abgeben
wer das video nicht gesehen hat kelly
und sturm haben ein waffeleisen und
zutaten wie sie in dieses waffeleisen
reinpacken sollen und daraus waffeln
machen sollen ja man hätte vorher schon
denken können dass das manchen wochen
nicht klappt aber ich dachte mir
challenge accepted kelly ich mach dir
diese traum waffen die ihr versucht hat
zu machen und das hat absolut nichts
damit zu tun dass ich irgendwie besser
kochen kann oder so das möchte ich
überhaupt hier an dieser stelle nicht
sagen ich möchte dir einfach nur unter
die arme greifen vielleicht kann es ja
sogar ein eigenes format werden also
wenn die videos habe die ich retten soll
ab in die kommentare damit am besten
auch videos das kann ich nicht ganz gut
die erste wahl für die studie zieht ist
kuchen
also lasst uns diesen kuchen versuchen
eine story time
ich war eigentlich schon gestern drehen
aber dann habe ich gestern migräne
bekommen und jetzt ist es 8 58 uhr 5
bevor wir darüber mit den waffen starten
können brauchen erstmal so ein grund
teig und wer besteht aus mehl eiern
butter backpulver zucker vanillezucker
und den ganzen anderen kram hier ist ein
bisschen mehl und da kommt ein bisschen
backpulver obendrauf und weil uns das so
gut gefallen hat kommt jetzt noch
vanillezucker rein und zu den trockenen
zutaten kommt noch ein stück butter was
ihr noch in eurem kühlschrank gefunden
habt und über nacht draußen liegen
lassen haben und es jetzt super weich
ist da ist jetzt noch ein bisschen
mineralwasser drin und wir wollen
natürlich für waffen
[Musik]
ok leicht
so sieht mein teil gibt es aus und
eigentlich sollte er viel flüssiger sein
weil ich aber für jede waffe auch so ein
bisschen andere kombinationen brauche
lasse ich den erst mal so und nehme mir
jetzt für den kuchen waffelteig ein
bisschen was ab für so frühe morgen
respekt ist aber jetzt geht's richtig
los retten wir kelis jetzt örtchen waffe
kuchen waffeln dafür brauchen wir ein
jetzt hört man packen er ist in eine
schüssel
vielleicht hatten wir es auch noch ein
bisschen klein das wäre ganz gut und
jetzt nehmen wir ein bisschen waffelteig
um so ein bisschen flüssiger zu kriegen
noch ein bisschen milch drauf und wir
haben unser jetzt gleich in den
waffelteig jetzt müssen wir das
waffeleisen anschmeißen und die
us-rocker machen
da habe ich gesagt dass ich kenne ich
waffe video rette nachdem meine erste
waffe so aus da habe ich gemerkt dass
ich den tag noch ein bisschen zu flüssig
gemacht habe und deswegen eine zweite
version probiert und darf sie doch gar
nicht mal so schlecht aus ich glaube
dass tatsächlich auf ein ganzes jahr
ich wäre aber nicht vanessa wenn das
schon alles wäre natürlich brauchen wir
für eine gute waffe lauf nahm und damit
man gleich erkennbar es ist jetzt in
krümmel obendrauf
ich würde food blogger ich schwöre euch
ich werde fit blogger wird er die waffe
video schon fast gerettet und jetzt
stellen uns natürlich wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt die
jetzt örtchen waffel aus dem video mit
sturm und caddy cool ist das lecker ich
muss aber auch noch andere als nächstes
versuchen kelly und stroh minute zu
einer waffe zu machen
dafür nehmen wir uns was von unserem
waffelteig und wir brauchen nutella
besseres gefühl der welt ich würde mal
sagen das ist ein guter teelöffel
nutella und der kommt alles in den mixer
and now that make it
unsere nutella waffe lasst uns mal kurz
de war fleißig probieren
danke meine damen und herren danke ich
bin hier jeden donnerstag und sonntag um
mein gott und wie sollte man eine
nutella rafi dekorieren natürlich mit
einem teller dafür nehmen wir uns einen
löffel nutella und streifen über die
waffe aber die wichtigste zutat fehlt
noch und nun stellen uns natürlich
wieder der allerwichtigsten frage wie
schmeckt die nutella waffel aus kelis
und sturmius video super idee rote beete
waffeln probieren sie als nächstes ich
habe noch nie rote beete sack gekauft
ich bin sehr gespannt
dafür brauchen wir natürlich mal wieder
einen löffel waffelteig und zudem
waffelteig gebe ich jetzt einfach mal
ein schluck rote beete saft und das
kommt wieder in den mixer wer kennt noch
die werbung
er riecht nach gemüse wie sollte er auch
anders riechen und das kommt jetzt in
die magische waffe maschine
und hier sehen sie eine pinke rote beete
waffe die sieht wirklich schön aus aber
natürlich ist sie noch nicht fertig ich
finde das aaa wie rupp dazu am besten
passen würde
ahorn und nun stehen wir uns um 300 mal
die allerwichtigste frage wie schmeckt
die rote beete waffe aus kellys video
mit ahornsirup kann man auch nichts
falsch machen wollte ist voll schön für
ihn von in lhasa schön absolute
empfehlung rote beete saft in einen
waffe teig reinzumachen erstens macht
ihn schön pink da muss ich nicht mehr zu
sagen und zweitens das schmeckt wirklich
gut wie bei karotten kunden denke ich
also man schmeckt dass es halt ein
gemüse ist aber es ist halt lecker und
damit würde ich sagen waffe gerettet
kommen wir zur nächsten wache die
gummibärchen waffe wird eine ganz ganz
spezielle waffel und zwar weil ich sie
nur für kelly zu bereiten das wird die
kelly waffel sein
und die geht so wir brauchen drei
schälchen die wir jeweils waffe kramer
13 jetzt brauchen wir noch eine pinke
blaue und gelbe lebensmittelfarbe und
damit firmwares die einzelne schiffe wir
nehmen jetzt unser aller vorteil
lebensmittelfarbe absolut fantastisch
vanessa wandert jetzt kommt der pinke
pinke waffelteig und zum schluss kommt
noch blauer waffelteig und jetzt noch
mehr eine waffe mit allen bereich farben
[Musik]
hier ist die erste kelly waffe ich habe
jetzt noch mal rein gemacht und die
farben so ein bisschen gemischt das sind
sie mit galaxy und so aussieht jedoch
selbst entscheiden welche waffe sieht
mir nach kelly aus ich finde ja
definitiv diese würfel darf ja kellys
erfindung ist müssen unbedingt
gummibärchen drauf und kellys waffe wer
nicht teddys waffe wenn da nicht noch
eine horn zuckerwatte draufkommt nehmen
uns mal so ein stück und für louis und
wenn wir beim thema schon sind dann
kommt noch ein paar smarties und nun
stellen uns natürlich wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt die
bunte kelly waffel mit ganz wie zucker
größte mobile hier wird aus diesem
kracher milchshakes waffe kann man auf
jeden fall machen okay die letzte waffe
ist nicht mal so eine richtige waffe sie
beißen einfach am ende in einer habanero
rein das ist eine extrem scharfe chili
schote und da dachte ich mir
machen wir doch eine sehr scharfe waffe
neben sturm war für wir brauchen
waffelteig und da kommen jetzt noch
chiliflocken rein
sowohl das recht wirtschaft über
treibens mann ist es soll eine scharfe
waffe werden und damit unsere scharfe
chili waffel auch so eine richtig
gefährliche fahrt nehmen die rote
lebensmittelfarbe und färben die wahl
ein weil das so viel spaß macht waffeln
einzuwerben
ok
okay aber waffelteig und ein letztes mal
machen wir das jetzt zu einer waffel
[Musik]
also diese waffe sieht nach vorsicht
scharf aus aber wie dekoriert mit zwar
eine scharfe waffe
man könnte eine gelbe mütze benutzen
oder süß saurer soße und einen klecks
schmand und den ganzen spaß natürlich
mit chiliflocken dekorieren und soll ja
sehen was ist eine erwartet ich würde
sagen das mit abstand die schönste und
nun stellen wir uns zum allerletzten mal
der fragen wer fragen die alle
existieren wie schmeckt die scharfe
waffe aus tennis und sturmius waffel
video wo sie waffeln machen aber nicht
so richtige waffen und nicht das brave
video gerettet habt wie sieht wirklich
appetitlich aus also wird der farbe und
dem mit dem schwanz laufen so dass sie
wirklich lecker offen
[Musik]
das ist eine scharfe waffe ok es wird
aber extrem lecker warum mag ich dass
david schafft und somit habe ich das
waffe video von kelly und stimmige
rettet wenn ihr noch weiter solche
cocktails videos hab dich retten soll
schatz in die kommentare das war witzig
und ja wie schmeckt kommt auch wieder
bald
und da sind noch zwei videos wo mein
gott das ist so ein chaos hier gut bist
dann tschüss eure meinung
macht